Hey Baba's joined I'm coming icy
blackness ah hello hi oh it's been a
while
oh yeah I don't remember it's done I
guess see it see you guys heard Wade
Wade there's a shark
no he's attacking you oh okay wait for
you in here and I can i snatch you know
I don't just jump right up there and
gotcha
where's the rock where's the ref there's
a shark ow oh my god mark have you
played before
yeah bleed wrap before my wrap pro right
good sure yeah yeah we all know what
we're doing
everyone knows what they're doing we
both missed it
all right so feel like we're put the
cart before the horse we we don't even
know why we're here we haven't
established the who we are and our
relationship to each other I mean I
thought I was here by myself and you
guys really popped out of the woods what
are you talking about brother wife mark
we're here on the brother raft I think
that you are the best raft tier in the
world
ah that's mighty kind of you brother
husband sure was strange for our sister
why husband to make it here with us
wouldn't sister husband Wade
well that's me sister husband Wade I'm
glad to be here I just liked building
wood so when you guys told me you're
gonna get lost in the middle of nowhere
with nothing I was like man can I build
some wood and know the rest is history I
think I think I think this might be the
cringes bit we've ever had I'm gonna die
no brother sister or husband I don't I
get more health look you got it anything
I'm otherwise eating yeah
you know why I don't know why they don't
make that shark like three times its
size like really beefed up this scares
that sure it's a shrimpy baby shark I
wanna oh no beefy shark I'm gonna be
scared of something it's got to be big
and beefy I've got a hammer so I can
build the raft for now if you guys want
to waste resource on the hammer
hey what's gonna be important soon food
and water we don't this island I don't
think we got a choice I think we're
gonna no we're gonna have to fly by it
we don't have any paddles or something
we need like an anchor could we build
anchor right away throw ball anchor we
need four rope four stone six point
something I don't have any stone I need
one more palm leaf and I can build us
all right Zeron well that kind of got
thanks for your help mark you're welcome
I will I was about to salmon to God yeah
now you get it wait how are we driving
over to the island are you doing that no
we just are looking into it this time
but it's not gonna stay we're gonna
bounce off of it as we don't have an
anchor I think you okay he's fine he's
just doing stuff where are you guys oh
geez don't leave me we have no control
over this we're just talking about this
where it goes you guys are gonna love me
because I picked up some watermelons
dude nice I'm pretty sure we can plant
those all right keep the sugar going for
me the shark away from me make sure yeah
I need more plastic we have a bunch of
barrels coming up better get some get up
get back get up gets barrels talked
about that I just got another plastic
I'm about to get this barrel over here
feel free to help mark I'm looking at
the crafting I'm looking at you're not
getting my watermelon
I don't want your watermelons I want
weights watermelon this you had my
watermelons you wish I got a spear all
right I can make another cup already Oh
mark I made you a cup thank you thank
you you can throw it on the ground okay
hey with a shark I don't see it anymore
I'll find it hey I got a stone is that
good there's two stones good sure did
you go underwater no I came out of that
barrel I just snagged though okay gotta
get those sweet barrels bro do these
barrels are sweet brother wife sister
cousin Marcus your cousin that's mr.
sister cousin to you I have a lot of
rope do you want a closet or something
why did you want us to like acknowledge
that in any way because I didn't feel
like it
spare some just can't stand the sound of
you talking okay someone put something
in the purifier perfer someone actually
I'll just drink my water and then put it
in the perfer the perfer I don't even
make a hammer I don't have stone yeah no
need to repair this I threw my oh no my
hooks here Oh what my hook is in the in
the infinite went into their way we
could make a paddle to get over to that
Island we could make a paddle yes we
need six plastic and two ropes that's
not happenin I have enough planks I
don't have enough plastics or ropes
where I don't have much plastic how many
ropes do you need to make a paddle I
make two rows got one rope too late
chumps is too more accurate new mom
rowing we're going to the island baby
maybe us is really cool no it's not
you're really you won't get us away from
all this good loot I was trying to okay
well too late oh I'm sorry do you want
to get it no no it's just some plastic
paddle away sister brother will I'm real
good at battling to make a normal anchor
I need one more rope and two more stone
and then I can anchor our jam I've got
one rope and one stone sadly oh hell
yeah I have everything now I'm making a
throw blanket [ __ ] sweet nice nice
nice that is nice max we can cut down
those trees for even more wood and there
should be underwater
maybe access to stuff we can who wanna
see stones right right below us I think
they look like stones there Rakesh
alright hit that anchor I'm not sure how
but yeah hey there's stuff down here is
so fast I've got a fishing rod you do
doing a fish mark yeah we sure also I'm
an excellent
I was always about the fishing crossing
Valley I do the fishing I did it I did
the fishing professionally I don't know
how to fish in this game though why I
never mind I figured it up
I got a rod to lap out propsal a fee oh
we're eating tilapia tonight I'm gonna
go under and just do doobie resources
[ __ ] all right you got it
how do we keep forgetting I just Oh
somebody drank the water oh no I needed
some of that alright to lap you boys my
my god guys there's a shark in the
island it's a Land Shark
no don't lie there was an EVP swim
walked away
oh it's cuz the waves are sloshing up on
the island knew this shark is out of the
water there's more of a land shark
that's what I'm sayin he's back kind of
a land is shirk alright I'm gonna hop
out of the water yeah but if I draw it
over I can stab it
whoa I'm in the water bonds for us I am
risking my buns for us and I don't know
why I don't make fun of me when I mean
[Music]
just destroyed my ass you saved mine
because I was in the world tilapia that
I was cooking that I caught I literally
just announced that I stole your -
laughing holy [ __ ] the shark just jumped
through the wrath to try and get your
ass mark Jesus Christ didn't get close I
got pretty close my pro digis ass you
guys were I just fight it the F Spears
we could just no you're the only one
with a spear alright don't fight it
I'll go find it here we go this is it oh
my god I think you would sure wish I had
my tilapia
oh my god I just picked up a giant clam
look out
Oh incapacitated Oh No wait wait someone
miss me gets me deeply hmm
you need to bed wake me up maybe you
need a bed
do we have a bed ah bed bed bed
I need nails nails I don't need it's the
second one it's other oh god okay pick
up the anchor we gotta go guys
help help help well help you're we need
to get a bed we need to get nails just
lift anchor anchor up like I can't
surrender I think you have to literally
jump in and get Wade go get that whoa
was it who's that anchor one-time-use
Oh maybe well thank yous go no its
one-time use I either that or else I
[ __ ] it in the help picking it up it
said remove no no not remove you picked
it up when is it in your inventory
it sure is not the anchor no we did not
get these barrels I'm paddling us
towards these barrels these barrels look
likely have the nails what happens if I
surrender and respawn is that bad you
can't respond that's cheating okay okay
you missed the barrel Wade it's right
here got it yeah I know I'm got it so
you got it
man Bob your corpse system right in my
way it's not as course he's still alive
he's gonna make me probably stop that
all right we stopped it all right time
to put a Pompeii on that I can make two
nails okay you have any scrub no I don't
everything I would have told you if I
had it I got plenty nails Oh bed so I
need four palm leaves do four palm leaf
uh yes
here I'll drop them there oh yeah lady
in there baby laid out did you honestly
doubt that we're trying to make a bed
for you yeah a little
what a good friend you are you know what
a good friend I'm alive that's fast all
I needed was like five seconds of nap
guys taking a nap on the ground
you were you were complaining about your
grants too hard
hmm you can now research antenna oh I
have a blueprint what does that do
receiver you used to locate nearby radio
signals what do I do with that I didn't
knew we could learn it I don't think we
can craft stuff like that till we have
more sophisticated things on this boat
sophisticated word yeah yeah I used it
yep you did sorry
our conversations are really good
starting to lose it on the other is
alright so there we go I extended this a
little bit around the bed we could
probably another linebacker
I got no water I need this we need to
start boiling water like crazy Ben I've
been cycling the water there should be
some in there did someone take it and
not refill it how there's water on there
fill your cup oh right oh god I drink
this water drink it I drink the seawater
I didn't mean to fill your cup with
fresh water I'm gonna keep the I'm food
man's well no mark has the fishing pole
though well it's almost dead actually it
died it really died well I can't make
one because it meets a trope which is
unreasonable amount of rope well make
rope then how in God's name do I make
rope with the leaves oh you do look at
that I only have two palm leaves that
only made me one rope well listen you
could keep finding things to complain
about her you keep finding solutions Bob
can everyone make some rope I have a
giant clam can I cook my giant clam just
pop a bad boy on the grill ride down
distel need food wait I ate one of the
fish I should be okay for at least a
minute I didn't need some water though
waters ready take the water all right I
took the water drank it down
wow that's pretty Savage mark thank you
from a man such as this nothing blue you
know I'm pretty I'm pretty crazy in
savage blow
[Music]
you know what I mean yeah bro you know
what I mean bro yeah yeah bro you know
blah I honestly feel like this is how we
might be if we were stuck on the open
ocean it's very slightly slightly insane
yeah slightly I'm going for full insane
that that's my I'm not insane I'm fine
I'm going once a night you me doctor no
mock me I address you by a proper
[Applause]
doesn't feel good I'm just out here
trying to grind ropes storage baby I'm
gonna break this store is gonna be base
materials like planks plastic and palm
fronds and rocks so feel free to take or
give oh look at all those poem things
you a-holes holding out on me
you got it I sure did all right
I extended this out another way this way
now I guess I'll go this way to picture
we protect the chest yeah and also make
it wide so we can make those nets being
a good man and I'm glugging up the
seawater me being a good man's in the
storms yep I'm whoa there we go extended
the boat once each direction there
you're the greatest
seagull what do the seagulls do can you
[ __ ] can you hunt them I think you could
eventually make a nest and they give you
eggs or something but also hell yeah
come lay your eggs over here so I can
eat your babies who's who's hungee Bobby
got cooked tilapias Wow yeah I'm gonna
make a small storage no I'm not
can someone make another small storage
and I'll start filling up a food store
and you took the plastic who took I'd
another right all the plastic here it's
five more in there five is not enough
we're really out of plastic right now we
are because the first reason Wade used
it all I was told to extend the boat on
the side no you sent me then yes we
don't have enough resources to make a
small box as we live in [ __ ] [ __ ]
plan I wanna make it very clear wait
gave himself that job no one gave him
that job girl Meghan Meghan another
small storage goodness calm baby I put
four more plastic in there no I got it
the swords done you rest your weary head
you fool the left storage is for food my
dudes
all right food big barrel over here on
my side don't make fun of me no no oh my
god Wade help me out triple triple
barrels there's also a raft straight
ahead we're gonna want to go to that
raft okay my paddle is almost dead so I
don't know if I'm gonna be able to help
on that we're kind of headed toward it
anyway but some will have to hop up and
loot that raft alright I see it I see
who you're volunteering well there's no
need to be rude I was Road Marc I will
so be it your throat tonight I will be
all over your throat you will so be it
oh you wish you knew how in the throat
that would mean yeah okay the same wid
you better you better you better be
careful that made it fun a Wade and
you're jumping in and attacking me and I
don't know why cuz I just I just hop on
whatever side seems to be winning hate
for you to have to experience that they
do for me to have to experience your
throat that's what I do things to make
another container some sort
no no container we need more plastic
have all these flowers and seeds do we
need flowers and seeds and things or is
that literally just cluttering my mind I
think it's decorative
my inventory is filled with seeds I
don't need yeah oh this [ __ ] that raft
is sinking
I've got nothing that good from it I got
some scrap metal I guess that's kind of
underwhelming just like you Wade
Wow and your throat why can't make
another chests do we need that oh no no
no I made it okay okay BAM so I'll have
you know under tools there is a thing
called shark bait
Bob if you get a palm for an ax herring
and that can distract the shark if we
don't want to kill it some you're
looting underwater for a bit interesting
I've not used it all that much I think
it is useful but I'm not personally
crafted or used it you know all right
I'm alive that's right we're gonna have
so much food guys in the food storage I
love it I love no idea no idea that I
love how our team just works hmm I love
our team just box yeah come here friend
mine give give to me damn you it's my
with the spirit help Wade you try you
couldn't you can't kill a shark so how
would you be able to kill me this Aston
is watching streams alright okay yeah
sure oh wait whoops I'm stupid I put
this in the wrong chest respect the
organization I'm trying to but Wade's
idiocy is bleeding over to me anyone
needed to rank anyone need a drink
there's a drink free I'll get it dranks
is up my bros room log and I'll replace
it because unlike Wade I like to keep
things nice and organized look at this
guy what a bro that's me a bro well I
was gonna get that Abraham Lincoln you
need some food are you gonna eat the
potatoes no I was gonna get the no the
the stuff that Wade stole from me this
food storage is not even gonna be big
enough once I get all this stuff yeah we
should start researching how to do like
a planter and stuff like that and
yada yada ya I'm gonna make our own
research table I think we need that
right yeah that sounds good whoa this
thing's big right at the head of the bed
so we can think and we can work while we
sleep
you see perfect we can funk and slop at
the same yeah I love a good thong and
slump please wait a minute a slot to
research place item 800 I'm researching
would did the Woodman sorry I looked at
it real good
oh yeah there's a raft over there he
looks like a big huh a big soccer big
honking boy over there although all of
my resources are in the chest so I don't
I don't have anything to make anything I
learned table no I holy [ __ ] my
knowledge spread to you guys mark you're
infecting me with your knowledge sure ah
corona style I can't stop it even if I
want to yeah
the bass student nothing what is this a
my inventory that I have right now
inventory scrap mechanic duck an old
plastic duck seems to originate from the
game scrap mechanic what what the f what
what what is this and why do I have it
Stones beer stone air oh dude nice nice
nice a smell paddling over there paddle
away for ya
there's a real man okay my paddle broke
anyone see my duck and can't explain why
I think it's just a little cosmetic
things they put in here starve and
dehydrate their food in the left one and
I just drank the wire Wade you're being
real pathetic hey being a real pathetic
I'm cranking on the foods there's no way
you should with a violent plastic we
need plastic repair Han I'll let me get
these barrels more more grilled up
pom-pom from grill net home and grill
them baby yum yum yum wait get the water
wait get the water get back to the boat
mark what you do why I
okay we're good we're good we're good oh
there's some water up and there's lots
of food going on I just can't
the boat is get on the boat yeah age it
deep can I help you in some way okay
there we go that's shark
what's so close to just yankin yeah sure
Lowe's sure just ignore the system just
eat those right off there that's fine
sorry Wow ooh collection net oh nice he
doesn't be good rug what an aesthetic
we're building an aesthetic on this raft
and I appreciate that my luggage I'll uh
cast etics
collection net baby they're facing the
wrong way aren't thank god they're good
they're good they're good collection net
baby yeah baby yeah baby baby shark baby
hey can I put on the side oh I can't ah
mark why are you sitting in a chair
contemplating life but I couldn't sit
and throw my hook at the same time did
you just make this a brooding chair on
the edge of the earth wait all the fish
waited so many fish here's some more
here's some beets for you bud thanks bud
which way let me extend mark toward your
thinking chair the other way
ah mark wants a space don't extend into
a sigh don't get yeah it's my phone I'm
sorry that's rude that's pretty yeah
yeah yeah back off my territory shark
attack just try and repair the shark got
good news guys more collection nets oh
hell yes get those get those things I am
getting those things bucket no [ __ ]
way bro [ __ ] it baby
we have crop plots by the way in case
you guys wanted crop points citizen
beets that way yes
we're currently low on planks just as a
FY FY you
well the collection nets are sea
be doing pretty spicy I'm getting stuff
oh look at this a surplus if we build
crop plots I think we're gonna need the
Scarecrow to keep the speech the
seagulls off of them right that makes
sense that checks out
that's logical I like that I can fish
while looking at my friends later I like
looking at you fish so it really works
out for the both of us you look at me
fish I'll fish while I look at you we
look at each other so now I catch fish
and I catch your gaze does anybody have
clay do we make clay or I sort of make a
wet brick oh yeah there was what we need
like one more clay there's sand in here
I put clay in there in research clay so
we need two more pieces of clay so we
need to find an island I guess to get
more clay is that where the clay is I
think it's like you can go get stoned
you can get sand or you can get clay
from like the ground
plus there's like random scrap metal and
stuff fun did we kill the shirt cuz I
don't see you then him he's swimming
around still you can kill it but he
comes back even if we do yeah but they
buy give us a chance to go down once we
get close to an island we should try to
kill him can we build like sails or
something yeah can you give me some palm
fronds Wade yeah I just need three thank
you and sail and this bad boy where we
put nod I figured out where I got the
duck from it's the same place that I got
this cat from anybody have any opinions
on where to put this sail before we just
go for it
somewhere in the middle I don't know I
don't know any think about this no one
can tell us we don't have a sail oh [ __ ]
I'm mid barrel I tried to that was my
hook got stuck my hook got stuck can you
make like a like a lot like a long
seeing thing what's that go along see my
glass
for optical purpose I see I link to the
due to the off the poet side right to
the right to the right yes the sail is
oriented properly all you do is hold our
and you move your mouse and it'll move
got it got it got it
do me play the paddle there's it
actually gonna take us just put the sail
face I don't know she's like it's taking
us toward it yeah we're extended another
row this way I don't know how far you
want to go each way before we put
collection that's on the sides and stuff
I mean do we need collection that's on
the sides I agree that's my opinion as
well all right that's a little too much
I'm gonna adjust our trajectory in a
moment here all right you got it
navigator Bob navigator chef Bob that's
me boys chef chef fisherman navigator um
how about a droplet well I've not been
drinking gotta gotta eat and drink keep
that strength up my dudes no way please
you promised you'd stop good the anchor
cuz we're we're just about here my dad
my chef Bob I've I've made you a treat
a treat if you investigate the ship
there's a new device yes how does this
work
Oh for growing what knots you gotta
attach it on the deck and then you pick
up the bucket and go swim down and drop
the bucket somewhere I mean I could just
keep the sail aimed at the island it
keeps kind of kind of makes you sure if
he made it just go just go stick that
down there and now we stuck okay so now
we should try to kill the shark and well
we could wait till daylight that way we
can actually see what we're gathering
underneath Oh see Shmi Shmi like
mannequins bone yeah that's the first
thing that I thought of too but I didn't
know we're thinking like gosh me was my
wife your mom I loved her she's dead now
no father yeah what a body she had
that's me your mom let's fight
Oh your mom yes I know great tits
god damn it I can't hit the shark to
save my life anyway about your mother's
tits oh yeah please go on great pair age
didn't do nothing knows you've got the
force you can read my mind just look at
the body memories look at my memories
all the great all the great images of
your mom's great tits are in there yeah
yeah sure we do Oh chef Bob we've got
some shark meat all right I'll let you
cook it up chef Bob
so unfortunately with the shark meat we
have the bigger grill but we should be
close to getting there now is exactly
when we should be underwater gangshim
underwater I am well I'm getting sand is
there clay too hopefully I got some sand
oh yeah there's goodies down here my
oxygen does not last yeah I guess
drowning is an ideal metal ore
interesting interesting interesting hold
your breath better yep pansy that's
what's wrong with you know what's wrong
with you when I suffer from rude disease
that sounds legit
I believe that where's clay what does it
look like it looks very similar to the
sand for when I could tell if I thought
it was just sand mmm that's not helpful
Oh see go get out of here go away how do
we make a scarecrow the sea girls trying
to mess up my jams or spear to like
hidden told the [ __ ] also who the hell
drank the fresh water and didn't refill
it wait can I have always where you feel
I've been refilling it unless I might
have forgotten once but I got another
clay
I think the clay is a little bit know
that one looks just like that okay use
words come on give me something
looks like saying it's clay I guess
that's what
that's what I deserve I mean these are
force but like you know I deserve worse
now Bob why do I deserve worse huh
that's pretty harsh judgment pretty
harsh judgment
okay I'm picked up one clay and I know
how to describe it it's a slightly
darker shade and it's a bit more rigid
yeah rigid that's the word I was looking
for I can't tell the color but it was a
little bit more rigid that's true Wow
I mean oh [ __ ] I should get out of the
water oh hi shark the surface of the
shark giving him the full business so
there's a wet brick laying right here
next in the research table to dry how
long does it take to dry I have no idea
never mess with the wet bricks before
shall we sail away or are we good here
another fishing pole soon and we're or
our fluid supply is gonna I will get you
that bye bye I got you well if we get
the big grill then I'm actually pretty
pretty rich with food cuz I got three
raw salmon three catfish and four shark
meats to cook up those bad boys mark
white white point oh there you go I'm
just trying to make more storage because
we keep running out yeah for how much
space the storage takes up it doesn't
actually store that much better when we
can get later on I'm sure there's a
better everything we can get later on
mark your sail placement really did [ __ ]
my grill placement oh I'm very sorry
I did ask I did ask you did ask is there
a way to wait can i oh wait oh I can
move it oh I'll put up my chair so I can
I can navigate without anybody getting
mad at me people in this third bill of
the second-to-last storage container
here
it didn't magically appear I made it I
wasn't taking credit that's one didn't
know it was there
get out of here seagull those seagulls
really don't like you guys I'm growing
us a watermelon and a pineapple yeah
praise me like you should all right
we get out of this beast yeah Nicole my
a bow is all right yo shark attack shark
attack comment I was here ready for you
you ain't gonna get new with them that's
what you were all over that dudes bag so
ready this is nice guys this is honestly
really nice it's too relaxing you know
that's very nice
I see skies blue I picked up a
drawbridge
should I put it in the research table
and I research to myself we learned a
smelter how do we make that oh it needs
six brick oh boy I don't think we have
that much stuff oh we didn't get enough
clay clay we did not get oh man we got
so many cooked wall fish shows why not
dude only because our resident fisherman
is so good at his job
I am fish main you better watch out and
me as our resident gatherer and the best
I'm great at my job too
wait what's your what to do a residency
and apparently nothing just uh
you also get select have some ambition
man I mean I've been in the raft I guess
yeah resident hammer man resident bill
burr man I like that
what menial labor the blazes have been I
feel like we're doing a bad job of
encouraging wait I was trying to be
encouraging it really didn't pan out
[Laughter]
hey guys I can harvest the things I got
one pineapple and one watermelon for all
of my troubles that's pretty good no I
get I guess how close are we to big big
big boys big what grill big grill all
right let me let me see if I can find
where the big
is okay big grill here it is advance
grill we need a metal ingot which means
means we need the smelter which so we
need to make our smell yeah another
island for or we make shark bait and go
down and go get it I don't know if we
can go down we need wrong pomfritt and
raw herring oh I'm cooking though it's
all God we need some kind of a snorkel
ah forget it because we need the snorkel
to go down here I bet anyway yeah I
would think lovely deep here would it
help if we made more grills you know and
and pretend it's bigger grills no the
problem isn't the quantity of grills I
can run them both myself right now it's
just that I have all this stuff that I
can't cook on this size a grill all
right well I've got something else
that'll make you happy happy defi
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]